Oh mets mon côté une vision doit avoir un mot
avec toi au nom de ton frère Quinn
Drew win frère mon frère mais j'ai
hâte de rencontrer mon frère monte d'un
cran oh mon dieu
[Musique]
Denis Johnson un  personne est assise sur
Kippour avril d'aujourd'hui un Inde kazuya
mishima de la synagogue robotique
qui passe notre devoir de le faire simplement
vous imaginez un petit mr.  Cappuccio solide lavage
attends je ne sais pas ce qui arrive Jim exactement
tu penses que tu penses loo ABC non le non
Leo jacuzzi ah tu vas m'en emprunter un
peu à 6 heures
yay whoo whoo ha ha pardonnez-moi oh ouais
c'est effrayant
[  Musique]
Anniversaire Harvie à toi Dan joyeux
anniversaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]